so good to see both of you Priyanka I
mean I'm some last time I saw you was on
Zoom uh funny enough I just celebrated
my 10th anniversary at ET Canada
congratulations and well the funny thing
is the day I audition is the day I met
you for the first time you were my good
luck charm it's crazy and I found a
photo of us I have no idea what we're
doing
okay
that's what we're doing but two muscles
it's kind of crazy
um that's bad I know thank you 10 years
I think we've aged by buying wine all
right fine wine yeah but it's been such
a an honor watching your journey and
everything that you've done over the
last 10 years and to see you at this
point as the first South Asian woman
part of a show like Citadel I mean thank
you for breaking so many barriers it
means the world I mean how does it feel
to be in this moment right now I mean I
have to say that you know this show yes
absolutely for an Indian actor or a
South Asian actor or an immigrant actor
coming into English language
entertainment
um is is very exciting but to me to
create a character to work on a
character like Nadia in um you know in a
genre that's monopolized by men which is
spy the Spy World you know there are
very few women that you can think of
that's exactly that have had really
amazing Kick-Ass spots and Nadia was
conceptualized
um like that like that was the whole
idea behind creating
um the relationship between these two
characters and that's what makes me feel
really proud that you know I've been in
the entertainment business now 22 years
and I remember how I it was when I
started it and the journey female actors
have taken in the last two decades and
I'm very proud of my colleagues and my
generation who pushed the envelope you
know demanded better parts for ourselves
you know and created Created them when
people weren't making it for them
there's so many
um actors Kerry Washington Mindy
um Nicole Kidman Reese Witherspoon
people who are like I'm gonna make my
show myself so it's just yeah
is about empowering to be able to see
you know characters like this which have
agency in their own lives on TV or in
the movies and Richard and Mason Kane
damn like when he comes after the eight
years the he's like the mi7007 with the
dad humor with the sprinkle of
handsomeness I mean it's everything I
mean in your perspective how would you
describe him I guess unique compared to
other spies that are legendary
um I don't know we talked about this
before I think there's a there's a huge
element of love to him and I think not
having that fulfilled much of his life
that makes him a slightly different to
other spies I know or have seen because
they're you know as much as as they
don't want to be they're driven by that
emotion yeah mainly
um which is which is kind of unexpected
for this by genre love's not really a
word that comes into it yeah it shows
very like and he's very complicated he's
very complicated yeah like all men right
I'm kind of geeking out because I'm such
a big fan of Game of Thrones Rob strike
the Red Wedding took me down but
thinking about it I feel like there's
some parallel to Nadia to Khaleesi yeah
absolutely both have like this quiet
confidence I don't know if you watched
it yeah right like any day I loved her
would you say so yeah yeah you take it
yeah I think it's so cool yeah and one
of the great things about this show is
about the idea that your memory is going
to be erased and it got me thinking
because I don't even remember what
happened last week but if you think
about it is there something that if your
memory was erased I take it away is
there something that you want to
remember forever
oh my gosh everything everything I'm so
grateful for my life I'm grateful for
the ups and downs
um you know I don't know maybe I'm
saying that because I'm in a
place in my life where I'm happy and
content and want to hold on to it just
the way it is and
um I I don't know if I want to make one
thing don't make me well I think dude
must be that one little experience that
you remember even from your childhood
Maybe
um
you know going on eating mangoes during
summer vacation my dad would buy mangoes
and put them in like any Himalayan
stream that we would be driving by and
they'd become ice cold because it was
you know Cold River and then we would
eat mangoes by a stream that's something
I really remember my dad and what about
you
was just my family I don't want to
forget them I think that's what happens
in the show is you meet a man who who
knows he's had a whole family before her
life or someone he's been married and he
has no recollection of that so I think
the idea of forgetting her family is
terrifying yes that's true and I watched
your chat with Jennifer sulky uh the
head of Amazon and it resonated in so
many different ways he talked about paid
parity you talked about global diversity
you talk about women empowerment and
last time we talked was about your book
I'm so curious to know when did you
realize or you felt that you were
acknowledge and you're finally seen
I think you have to try to be seen every
day I don't think you ever reach a point
even if you're popular which is a
byproduct of my job you know like you
I'm an actor but the fame comes along
with being a public person
um but I think being seen doesn't
necessarily mean having a face blasted
over Billboards being seen and being
heard means you know people taking your
opinions seriously giving you respect
and Credence
um and I think that takes time you can't
demand respect you have to command it
you have to build over time and I think
it's a it's a journey that will exist
for everyone you know for a long time
because you different situations and you
have to make sure that you're seen and
heard without having to yell
I love that uh and this starts off I've
seen the first three episodes and you
start off with the red lips the red
dress and like you're in this sharp suit
and the ACT action just kind of collides
tell me about the stunts I know you got
some bruises I understand that you got
some bruises from it but did you enjoy
it did you enjoy the stunts did you was
there a scene you're just like oh this
is too much for me for both of you yeah
yeah you enjoy the pale format that's
always great we're watching it in the
end at the time you eat it and you're
sore or you're bleeding or you know it's
it's so very difficult but at the end
you see on screen you're like oh yeah
that's really cool that looks great it's
the payoff for the end yeah well
congratulations I can't wait for
everyone to see this it is absolutely
amazing and congratulations on season
two I mean it's not even out yet and
already season two so congratulations to
both of you so good seeing you good to
see you